[Music]
that's worse than life i got here at 6am
you were first in line oh yeah i've been
going since
2001. i've always had a huge respect for
apple retail i'm from new jersey so i've
been to all the ones in
in like manhattan being first in line
for an officer opening it's sort of like
being in the first
row of a roller coaster you know what's
coming this guy knows what's coming the
next guy knows i'm covered
but i get to see it first
[Applause]
tim is here and he's greeting everybody
at the front of the store
this is incredible
congratulations the store is beautiful
it's amazing thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
the tower theater is such a special
location and it's such a huge part of
los
angeles history and this is also one of
the largest restoration projects that
apple has ever done to date for one of
their iconic storefronts
this theater was originally designed in
1928 by theater architect
s charles lee it was one of the first
theaters in los angeles wired for film
with
sound and it was also the first theater
with air conditioning
it was officially closed as a theater in
1988 and it was used very rarely for
concerts or film shoots
and now its history has been brought
back to life by apple
i was able to see the store the day
before the grand opening
and being able to just really admire the
attention to detail in this restoration
was incredible
one of the cool things to note is they
really did try to keep as much original
pieces in this place as possible so all
of this obviously has been restored
but there are new hand railings and
things that they had to put in place
so you can tell that they kind of tried
to keep the same look but not try to
mimic the old style too much
[Music]
tyler just asked me if i have anything
to say i am actually speechless
i know it's surprising i've been to a
lot of apple stores but this doesn't
feel like something
that's real like everything just looks
absolutely beautiful this feels like
just some sort of european vacation in
los angeles
i guess i did have something to say
[Music]
the attention to detail like everything
has been completely restored
like i was watching some of the videos
that they have of the restoration
process
it is unbelievable the amount of things
that they have done to this place to
make it what it is today
have you ever seen somebody unbox all
seven colors of these imacs
[Music]
here's two historic theater seats so
these are actual seats
that were in the theater they i think
have been cleaned
the crazy thing is everything looks so
old but yet it's also clean and new so
it's really confusing
in my mind they've added a lot of
accessibility features
so on a lot of these displays they have
braille
under all of the art pieces so this
place previously was all steps there
were no elevators so they did install
some elevators so it's easy to get into
the store for accessibility
and over here they have some nice areas
that'll take you right from the elevator
and you wait for your genius bar
appointment i thought there was going to
be cup holders here just because that's
the type of person i
am but even better there's outlets
i'm leaving the lake i'll be back
uh-oh oh gosh i'm here forever
thank you you're very welcome
oh my gosh today is the day that the
apple store tower theater is opening
this is the grand opening like this is
it there are people waiting in lines
there are some really fun surprises i
saw brian is here and also crystal
let's go say hi so the last time i saw
you was a ces
that's right we were all masked up not
vast yet
and we had to stay very far away i know
not anymore are we allowed to do this
we're hugging this is amazing okay you
know what's crazy about this um
being at an apple store working there 10
years ago and now being here
at a grand opening and we've been at
other kind of like launches i think
we've like met
at the ipad launch before yes it was the
original ipad yes yes
i thought i have that yeah yeah so it's
just kind of fun that like we're here
again
i know but we met on myspace
i just want to say like i honestly
didn't know if you ever remember that no
of course yeah i grew up in the middle
of nowhere nobody liked the things that
i liked so i literally was on myspace
trying to find other people that liked
apple and this was before youtube just
before anything so we were like
e pen pals i was like oh my gosh this
dude
this is so cool he works at an apple
store and then here we are
like that's kind of crazy if you think
about it i mean that was 2000
oh i don't know how that had to be like
around 15 years ago
[Music]
okay so crystal is here as well this is
so weird i haven't seen you in so long
i know it's been a while like probably
one of the wwdc's a couple of years ago
now yeah that's how you wow so now we're
here
how's it going are you excited about
this i am excited i feel like this is so
different and new right now like
just seeing people in general is
exciting yeah and we're celebrating an
apple store launch
i mean this place is beautiful it's oh
my gosh i'm so excited i haven't seen
any of the inside yet so i'm just
very very excited i know it's a lot of
history behind it a lot of culture in it
too so
we're going in let's do it very soon are
you excited
yes tim is up there we're gonna get gift
back
okay i didn't hear that
i am in tears no joke it's like this is
so emotional like actually seeing people
for the first time
at the apple store i love all of your
classes
i'm so excited to meet you all
apple fitness has basically changed the
way that i'm able to work out and i'm so
[Applause]
glad
[Music]
so i just got out of the store it was
honestly so emotional i started crying
because
it was just not only is the store
incredible but just seeing so many
people happy
and after not seeing people for so long
just being able to see people happy and
enjoying something again
was honestly so overwhelming the store's
amazing and i hope that you guys get a
chance to check it out
i'm overwhelmed i'm so happy what a
great time
you